でお釈迦様は付け加えて
母にもできぬことを父にもできぬこと
己の心を育てると自分に得られるんだよという偈を唱えたということなんです
ストーリーとエピソードは合わないだけの話です
私はダンマパダではあまりストーリーはあまり言わないんですよ
ストーリー合ってる場合もあるし
合ってない場合もあるし
このエピソードももう
なかなかもう偈と合わせるのは大変難しいんです
偈の注釈は まあストーリーとエピソード関係なく
注釈は別にあるんです
注釈は生まれた人にとっては
世界で両親以外自分のことを心配する存在はいないんです
で 現代人は母のことも父のことも気にしないとか何とか言っても
それで威張って言っても
結局は不幸のどん底にいるんだということが叫び声しか私には聞こえません
せっかく人間に生まれたのに
なんて不幸なやつかと
それは自分の過去の業で
私は知ったことではありません
しかし 誰でも親から生まれるもんなんですよ
生まれた自分のことは最高に誰が心配するのか
自分の幸せを徹底的に誰が願っているのかというと
それは誰もないんですよ
これは両親なんです 他の人も心配しますよ
親切してくれますよ しかし
両親には勝てる勝てっこはないんです
両親ほどやってくれるということはないんです
時々親が亡くなって他人に育てる場合もありますよ
全く母親と同じくやってくれる時ありますけど
両親じゃないんだからね
そういうことだから 一番一般的に言えば
人のことは徹底的に心配するのは両親です
他の人も心配はしますよ
親戚やら上司やらみんな思っている中とか
でもあれほどこの強烈な繋ぎは絆はないんです
これはもう永久的な絆で
全く切ることは断つことはできない
なのに親にもろくなことはできないんだと
自分に対しては あれほど心配しているんですけど
産んだ子供に対してはもうどうったこともできないんですよ
ただ育てるぐらいのことで
だから最高に心配する両親にしたっても
まあ育てるぐらいのことしかできない
しかし 我々は自分の心を管理するならば
想像を絶する幸福が得られますよということで
いかに自分の心をコントロールすること
心を育てることは大事でしょうか
ということは言ってる偈なんです
サンマーパンニタンチッタン
正しく育てた心をセイヤソーナンたとかれ
彼を偉大なる人物にするんだよと
母にもできない してあげることはできない
父にもしてあげることはできない
しかし 自分一人でできますよと
最高なレベルまで自分の心を持っていくことはでき
育てることはできます
ということで 何よりも自分の心のことを気にしなさいよという
それが唯一の価値なんです
一番大事な もう絶対的に大事な仕事は何なのかというと
自分の心を育てることなんです
いうことを言ってます
終わりです まあそれは仏教の文化では
このまあ子育てであろうとも
教育であろうとも いつでもこの道徳
人格 それが 第 一 にするんです
なぜかというと 慈しみは基本にしているんだから
親にしても両親にしても
じゃあ子供に何をしてあげればいいのかと
それを贅沢してあげればいくらでもやりたい気持ちはあるんだけど
そんなのは意味がないんだと
教育させれば それは当たり前
教育はさせますけども
でもそれも最高なものを与えたことになりませんと
だから子供にとっても
もう両親としてはもう最高なものを与えたいという気持ちがありまして
いい人間になれということを言うのです
すごい短い言葉です いい人間になれ
医者になれじゃないんです
何があっても殺される羽目になっても
罪だけは犯すなよと 輪廻転生するんだよと
道徳を重んじるんです
学校でも同じことを言うんです
勉強できたんだからといって調子に乗るなよと
性格は何よりも大事だよと
勉強できなくても 思いやりのある子は一番立派だと
ということはずっと我々には言い続けてきたんです
今はわかりません もう半世紀も経ってるんだから
その時でも まあいつでも最高なものを与えたいという気持ちなんですよ
人が何を勉強しても 性格が悪いならもう仕事はないんです
社会人にはなれません
たとえ勉強できなくても
ものすごい信頼できる
思いやりのある 人のことを心配する
正直な人間なら いつでも仕事はある
安心して生きていられる
それで悪いことをしないんだから
死んで地獄に落ちるわけでもない
だから母親として父親として
それだけは子供にはちゃんと教えてあげる
そうすると一番意味のあるものを与えたことになります
うん まあ一応そこら辺で話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
[咳]